oh my God you have to see the new Disney
trailer all right get this get this
they're remaking the Little Mermaid can
you believe that you can the Nostalgia
though bro I'm gonna play it
look at the duck it's Ariel
I can see it fine I don't know what
you're talking about here here let me
turn up the brightness
can you see it now you're exaggerating
it looks fine yeah it's dark because the
ocean is dark
it's real as wow well what did you think
I think you need to get your eyes
checked because that was a very well lit
image okay just shut up it's not even
about the visuals as much as as it is
like the music like you hear the music
and it's like oh my God oh my God you're
transported
you weren't transported